hello and welcome to zero playing Grand
Master Sega sleep park oops come on I'm
going to play an Enzo oh wow too late i
don't see that all it's a lot a bad
opening line actually it's very very
comparable to them um to the tutors to
the classical with 96cm 96 is probably
not the best line but I'm at least is
what I know so I'm going for it a very
bad scoring instant one out of five well
it's not great
ya know a three is the most normal move
now why to choose between be 44 III g3
they're all very playable before he is a
somewhat rare move so the reason is that
quite often I get in this takes takes it
doesn't doesn't really prevent it so
don't see it check out he has ignored
this idea which is quite often promising
for black or at least interesting
promising it can be but it's usually
interesting I'm busting open the
position very very quickly so um see
sixes the move that I want to play I can
take I can place here six immediately
okay i'll shoot for c6 immediately it's
very it's very sharp approach but the
one thing that I've got going in for my
position at the moment is that I am
already castled and why does not so this
is something they can try to maybe bust
open the position very quickly if it
takes p5 I have 94 or night before they
both are quite interesting if I take
before queen bee three to five bishops
III could be an interesting option so
probably I have to jump to deform play
this position
the idea now is to go 85 and the tekkit
before i think i actually have analyzed
this this kind of stuff in my book and
not quite sure what to what to make make
of this ok taking before is the normal
looking move but he's got a five which
is of course of course pretty annoying
if I've takes 94 take a couple of their
room it's not great it's not great
and you try this hard to play it's a
position where I'm not sure I mean maybe
I'm just do us but if not you have to be
very technically precise here to be
active enough and get your get your porn
bag and not sure that I'm that I'm doing
this to set the moment being precise
rather not I guess ok anyway there is
some pressure on those two pawns if I
get one of it back then I'm certainly ok
let's see what he's doing I cannot take
on d5 the whole time as age 7 is hanging
with the check which is rather bad ok
maybe a good time to do this now
maybe I'm able to get one of the points
back and to be okay a very likely this
should should be okay should be working
they get one back queen here or queens
III m23 don't know about that 26 s also
like to see form as a as a possibility
23 that's just be six I think and this
is this is kind of awkward you know this
is also awkward if I have to play
something they don't want to spend even
more time yeah good move i guess cannot
take
and doesn't look good looks like I
should be should be in huge trouble I
just blended the damn night now come on
why am I playing [ __ ] against the
sky is really weird against some people
I just cannot get anything going i have
a absolutely ridiculous go against him
and again playing some some nonsense
game here then some Pleasant players you
just cannot handle I don't know what it
is yeah thank you for it's very
difficult or what was he asking just
himself why not resigning okay there's
no particular reason why I'm not
resigning it's just that I just don't
like to do it whatever happens I what a
stupid game
black resins gym yeah it's okay this is
interesting and I don't think it's bad
which didn't work out well this is this
I know in 35 this is really bad I time
this yeah maybe this is too lame or
anything I don't know yeah I'm in
trouble yeah Quincy sixes again is a
strong movement here i'm not i'm just
not getting out of it I mean here I
don't do it I don't have a good move
anymore but I should see the head 25 as
plundering the night I just didn't work
out maybe the maybe this opening idea
was a bit too too much I mean this this
was not working I think after twin be 30
lat Queen a 7 which that's strong don't
even understand that what's happening
here so if it does that I have no g4 Wow
okay so okay okay but this right okay
yeah this is clearly better i come to
the engine i couldn't believe in the
night before because the night has no
squares and d5 is not so easy to play
that means i have to do 90 form and then
we get this maybe this is just not good
it's very much possible this is the
computers mainline cancels rook c8 and
yeah
and white is still better here yeah
maybe this is just a bad idea this is
this idea is well known from this
opening but it might be a case where it
is not not not great simply the engine
actually wants to play this here and
we're just kind of surprising checking a
bishop first it now it now gives this
funky line check it's kind of remarkable
yeah okay okay good that cannot be
grateful black okay maybe I have to play
keep it simple let's say I didn't want
to allow him to take that in one move
but maybe this is what I have to do I
mean here I'm not materially down at
least huh yeah I guess it was just a
good game from what I didn't have any
big opportunities them okay so thanks
for watching